With the rise of the Islamic state, or Daesh,
back in 2014 we witnessed the terrible
and awful crimes that they committed
against the religious minorities in the
region. And some of the worst of these
crimes were committed against the Yazidi
community, particularly in the Sinjar
Mountain region, which garnered a lot of
international attention of course. But
this also led a lot of people to ask the
question: "Who are the Yazidis?" and "What is the Yazidi religion"?
The Yazidis are referred to as an ethno-religious
community, and one that is specifically
connected to the Kurdish people of
northern Iraq in regions like Sheikhan,
the Sinjar mountains and in the region
of Lalish. Now, what we mean by
ethno-religious community is that the
religion and ethnicity is so strongly
interconnected that we cannot really
separate one from the other. This is
shown by the fact that your
religious identity as a Yazidi is primarily
determined by your parents being Yazidis
and that the religion doesn't accept any
converts. We usually understand religion
from a very modern and often Christian-
centric framework in which religion is
often separated from things like
politics or ethnicity, but this example
shows us that the world of religions
are a lot more complex than that and
that these divisions aren't usually all
that clear at all. The name "Yazidi" is
contested and there's no consensus on
where it came from or why it was applied
to this group in particular. Some
connected to the middle Persian word
"Yazad" which means "divine being'', others
think its origins may have been the name
of the second Umayyad caliph Yazid Ibn Mu'awiya
whom the group that became the
Yazidis are said to have sympathized
with. Yazidism has for the majority of
history and even still today had been a
primarily oral tradition. This means that
there are no sacred texts or canonical
collections of texts in which their
beliefs or practices are gathered or
have a direct source. Instead,
beliefs and practices have been orally
transmitted by the religious leaders
throughout the centuries. This also means
that there are many different, often
competing, understandings of basic
tenets and elements of the religion and a huge
variety in how its practitioners
understand and often relate to it. This
of course is true for all religions but
particularly so for Yazidism because of
its very strong oral tradition and the
lack of any texts at all. There
is no proclamation of faith that Yazidis
affirm and no unity in terms of
performing rights or prayers or how
these are to be performed. This means
that it's hard to talk about the Yazidis
in any kind of generalizing terms, but
there are a few generalization is that we can make about
the general ideas or theological
tendencies and and practices of this
religion. Yazidism is usually described as
a monotheistic religion. This means that
they believe in one Almighty God who has
many names including Xwede and Allah.
Arguably then, this is the same God as
the Abrahamic faiths as Yazidism
share many of the mythological basics
of these religions, which we will see. But
this one God is so transcendent that he is uninterested in earthly or
worldly affairs.
Instead he focuses on "heavenly affairs"
and leaves the ruling or governing of the world to seven angels.
These angels are called the "Haft Sur"
or the "Heftad". The most powerful and
important of these angels is called
Melek Taus - "the peacock angel". He is the
leader of the seven angels and have been
given the responsibility to do God's
will on earth. Melek Taus or the peacock
angel has thus become one of the most
prominent and important symbols for Yazidism as you can see on many logos or
in symbols to represent this religion.
Another prominent symbol used by Yazidis is the
Sun which represents God and his
creative power, and as a result of this
Yazidis pray facing the Sun.
These angels are also thought to be able to take
human form almost like an avatar in the
Hindu tradition, and have done so
throughout history. These incarnations
are known as "khass". As an example, some
Yazidis believe that Jesus and the early
Muslim theologian and mystic Hasan
al-basri are two examples of this "khass".
Yazidis also believe in the process of
reincarnation after death rather than
the more common monotheistic concept
of heaven and hell. The origins of the
Yazidi religion is another point of
contention where there really isn't any
consensus. They share the mythological
background stories of the Abrahamic
faiths, and they trace their religion to
Adam, the first man. In fact, they often
hold that their people are descendant
from a miraculously born son of Adam
called Shehid Ibn Jerr, and from that
point on the Yazidi religion is often
traced through Babylonian, Sumerian and
Mithraic cultures. What is perhaps most
important to Yazidis is that they
consider their religion to be the original religion of
the Kurdish people and that all Kurds
before the coming of Islam were Yazidis.
Thus, there's a clear line often drawn
here between Yazidism and Islam which
one should accept in one sense, but that
division or strong division also becomes
slightly problematic when we view the
more scholarly historical evidence. In
fact, Yazidism enters the world
stage in the 12th century and
particularly in the region of Lalish,
which is still a central region
for the religion today. Here, they seem to
have first appeared as followers of a
Sufi Sheikh by the name Adi Ibn Musafir, more commonly known simply as
Sheikh Adi. He seems to have come originally
from modern-day Lebanon and later
studied in Baghdad under, or along with,
some of the most famous Sufi scholars in
history, like Abd al-Qadir al-Jilani - founder
of the Qadiriyya order - and the two
al-Ghazali brothers Ahmad and Abu Hamid.
It seems that later in his life he chose
to live a life of seclusion and
re-settled in Lalisg in the Kurdish
mountains where he founded a Sufi order
that he called the Adawiyya. This Sufi
order, many scholars argue,
is the foundation that would become
Yazidism later on. It was very
characteristic of Sufi sheiks and
missionaries in particular to be more
let's say intolerant or open towards
local traditions in regions that they
went into. So they were often, in
their practice, adopt local practices of
the older religion or
tradition and sort of give it a new
Islamic clothing to easily
transition the population to a new
Muslim identity. This fact, along with the
geographical isolation of the region of
Lalish and its people (and the Sufi
order) led to its gradual development
away from it's Sufi or Islamic
roots into its completely own tradition
eventually. Both Yazidis themselves and
modern historians and scholars agree on
the importance of Sheikh Adi for the
religion of Yazidism, but they have
different perspectives on who he was.
Yazidis is often say that he was a
reformer of the already
existing Yazidi religion, and there are
different opinions on whether this was a
good or a bad thing.
Those in favor him often claim that he was never actually a Muslim
but really a Yazidi in disguise who only
claimed to be a Muslim to avoid being
persecuted by the Sunni majority.
Scholars and historians however agree
that in Shaikh Adi's writings we find no
trace of Yazidism and that by all
accounts he seems to have been an
Orthodox Sufi Muslim who
created a sufi order that was within the
fold of the mainstream Islamic
religion, and that the deviation
or separation into it's own religion
eventually happened or developed
after his death. These possible roots in
Sufism can also sometimes be very
clearly seen, for example, in terminology
used in the religious practice. Yazidism and it's people are very much
divided into a kind of caste system and
in this caste system there are a number
of castes, obviously. The lower caste of
the majority are known as "Murids".
Above them are the Pirs or Elders who
function as spiritual guides and
religious clergy basically. And lastly
the highest caste which are the
Sheikhs or masters who seem to have had a
rather similar role to the Pirs but
even more exalted. They are sometimes
thought to have healing powers for
example. For those of you who know your
Sufism or Sufi terminology you'll
recognize these terms, as they are the
same words that are used in the hierarchy
of the Sufi orders, or in the Sufi
practice generally. Murids in Sufism
denotes a student of a master, also known
as a Sheikh. Pir is also often used as a
name for the leader of a
certain Sufi order. In any case, these
castes have played and still do play an
important role in Yazidi practice. Like
with many other religions, Yazidism can
be characterized primarily as a religion
of orthopraxy rather than orthodoxy. This
means that they put more emphasis on
cultural and traditional
practices and on taboo and things
like that rather than having certain
beliefs or following a theological
doctrine. The caste system and the ethnic
unity of the Yazidi people is very
important. This means that one is very
rarely allowed to marry outside of the
religion and usually not allowed to
marry across castes either. This is in
fact even more frowned upon than
marrying outside of the religion all
together. So the role of Murid or
Shaykh is hereditary.
If one marries outside the religion, that
person is usually excommunicated and no
longer considered a Yazidi. The actual
practice of the religion is often
connected to these ideas of taboo and
different traditional cultural practices.
There are festivals celebrated around
the year, like the Yazidi new year which
is celebrated in April. But the most
important festival of the year is
probably in the one known as Jamiyya or the
feast of assembly (the festival of
assembly) which take place over the
course of seven days. And this festival
is celebrated in honor of
Sheikh Adi, and during this festival Yazidis
make a pilgrimage to Sheikh Adi's grave
in Lalish and there they perform
religious rites, they listen to Qawl
(religious hymns) and stories, and
generally just get together as a
community.
Yazidis also traditionally do personal
daily prayers which are said to be five.
As with other minority groups the
Yazidis have in a lot of periods received less than
ideal treatment. They have for a large
portion of history been under the rule
of Muslim empires and kingdoms, and this
on-and-off persecution/oppression by the
Muslims can be traced, as in so many
other cases, to social and political
factors. So during the Ottoman era, for
example, the Yazidis were sometimes
tolerated, usually when they could be
beneficial to the Ottoman state and the
Sultan's by serving in the army or
things like this. But in other periods
they were often very much oppressed and
persecuted for, according to the ottomans,
not paying their taxes and refusing to
serve in the army. And of course there is
also religious grounds for much of this persecution as
many christians and muslims in history
have referred to as Yazidis as devil
worshipers. This is related to the story
of the highest angel that i mentioned
called Melek Taus. According to Yazidis,
Melek Taus was asked by a God to bow to
Adam, the first man, to which he refused
because he didn't want to bow to anyone
except God himself. So this was done out
of love for God. And because of this he
was exalted as the highest of the angels,
he was given the highest position. Now, of
course this is similar, or almost
identical, to the story of Iblis or
Satan in the Quran and the biblical
account. He was also asked to bow to Adam
to which he refused but in that story
God then punishes him for this refusal
to follow God's orders. So this is
why some Christians and Muslims have
identified the the Melek Taus of the
Yazidis with the devil or Lucifer of the
Abrahamic faiths. This claim the Yazidis of course
deny, but being called devil worshipers
doesn't exactly help your reputation and
has often led to violence or
justification for violence such as with
the Islamic state in 2014. But as a
result of things like this the Yazidis
were often not considered the among the
"People of the book", the Ahl al-Kitab, by the muslims and thus didn't retain the same
rights as groups like christians or jews
or sometimes Zoroastrians and so on. By
the end of the Ottoman era the Yazidis
migrated from the Middle East to a large
extent and after the events of 2014
migration has become even more prominent.
It's hard to know how many Yazidis there are
currently in the world, estimates can
range between 200,000 to over a million.
The large population that previously
lived in the Sinjar mountains was
severely minimized in 2014 with the
genocide as 80 percent fled to other
regions or other parts of the world
completely. Yazidism therefore has a
significant diaspora community in Europe
today. This new situation of entering
regions of the world that they
historically haven't and living as a
diaspora community has led to, as it
often does, questions regarding
integration and the levels to which one
allows the religion to be adapted to the
new societies. A prime example of this is
the fact that Yazidis traditionally
haven't been allowed to learn how to
read or write except those in the
highest (and smallest)
Sheikh caste. Reasons for this doctrine
isn't all that clear. Some say was meant
to keep the religious teachings secret
and confined to the Sheikh lineage, the
religious clergy. Others say was
to avoid being educated and Islamic
educational systems and schools.
Nonetheless, as the Yazidis entered
new regions like Europe it could become
quite a problem if you didn't know how
to read or write, so these  ideas have been
loosened up and since the 1950s the
Yazidis, especially in diaspora communities,
have tended to be allowed to read and
write. And this is just one example of
other forms of discussions and
debates about levels of compromise or
integration that is allowed to modify
religious traditions. So as you can see,
Yazidism is a very diverse
and complex ethno-religious community
that is very hard to define in a lot of
cases. It is clear that even if it does
have its origins in a Sufi order (the Adawiyya of Sheikh Adi) as many claim, it has
throughout history developed into its
own religion and its own unique
tradition completely that is separated
from the religion of Islam. Thus, it can
tell us a lot about the myriad and vast
array of different religious groups and
minorities that exist in the Middle East
today. I'll see you next time.